now remember when New York Governor
Andrew Cuomo claimed that he needed
30,000 vents within two weeks well if he
didn't get them he said people were
gonna die is really scary well we at the
Ingraham angle were skeptical that
number seemed absurdly high based on the
revised data which we started talking
about on Tuesday night with doctor foul
Qi well it turns out we were right yes
there's a stockpile because that's where
they're supposed to be because we don't
need them yet we need them for the apex
well joining me now is Rudy Giuliani
former New York City Mayor Rudy it's
great to see you tonight well he said
they're in a stockpile where they're
supposed to be the president seemed a
little perturbed today that they send
they send a lot about 4,000 I don't how
many exactly arrived but they're a lot
and they're not deployed anywhere
they're just sitting there but what
about Cuomo in is he just taking care of
his state the way he should be
maybe over projecting but why is that a
bad thing first of all I think by and
large he's done a really good job and
and the president has done a superb job
there is a tendency to overstate for
your state I went through this a number
of times with West Nile virus with
anthrax and of course on 9/11 I tried
not to and I tried not to because I
don't want to lose credibility in one
case I was dealing with Bill Clinton so
I was dealing with the opposite party
the other case I was dealing with
President Bush but I also understood the
presidents got demands from all over the
world all over the country you know in
the case of anthrax so I don't want my
demand to look ridiculous now this looks
like a case where they didn't know I
mean the righthand didn't know what the
left hand was doing which can happen in
a situation like this so you start to
back off maybe you make a little apology
for it the most important thing is good
relations yeah I think that's right I
think the president has said many times
which I think again is why his numbers
not that that's what important but I
think people like the fact that he says
I'll work with anybody to get this
country going again and to protect
people I don't care where you come from
what party you come from
what company you come from I'll work
with anybody that's the kind of thing we
need to hear in a crisis in my view and
I think you know just eleven you did the
same thing a little advice
for the governors and the mayor's having
been in that position in three
extraordinarily difficult situation I'd
say one equal to this take the blame
when you have to you know if you play
with your boss sometimes it's better if
you don't win the golf game he's the
boss he's got all the resources I I
don't say that he's going to be affected
and giving out resources one way or
another but it's just human nature that
if you act like a responsible guy and
he's got real confidence that you you're
doing what you're doing he's gonna give
you everything you want I think you
could ask President Bush to this day I
don't think there's a single thing I
asked him for he didn't give me right
away and I don't think there's a single
thing I asked him for that I didn't
really really need so that's the kind of
confidence that has to develop I thought
that what's happening between Trump and
Cuomo Trump maybe even a nuisance so
let's see let's see if we can get back
on it but by and large compared to some
of the others like my completely absent
mayor Cuomo is a hero I think don't have
to belabor the point but de Blasio has
been smashing the president what a
prison yeah this crazy judge on just
yesterday Rudy let out this guy who
stabbed his girlfriend multiple times in
the chest from Rikers ordered him and 15
others released because a legal a
society petitioned the judge because
they're worried about their health at
Rikers Island I'm thinking this guy just
murdered it it's got murdered his
girlfriend in June of 2018 this is the
case I'm putting up on the screen for
you and now this guy is going to go free
a murderer
but have they really gone wacko I mean
the fact is the reason they're arguing
they should get out of Riker's Island is
RIKEN Rikers Island is rampant rampant
with coronavirus so we are putting out
on the street people coming from a place
that's rampant with coronavirus into a
city that's the end of the street
virus and I'm being told to stay home
I'm being told the state in my apartment
don't leave or as little as possible I
mean this is crazy
I wanted to bring to your attention dr.
Zelenka report I hope you saw that 669
cases treated with the hydroxy quinolone
and these is her Max and he adds ink to
it so far 669 cases five
hospitalizations to intubations no
deaths and we're talking about a large
number of people over 70 years old so
I'm going to keep a close track on more
thing yeah we're seeing great results
but Rudy's you've seen this in your
career in politics and and and and in
your time in government federal
government and state government but
there you get the sense that the media
they don't almost some of them don't
want things to go back to normal in the
United States they they like this crisis
point they really don't want things to
go back to normal and a lot of them seem
as the news comes in that might be
slightly better than we thought they're
angry or and grumpier than then then
they should be it's odd I could hardly
find for sneeze readjustment I try I
tried to I mean I heard it and I wanted
to see it again because I wanted a say
in an interview this morning the exact
words the force he said done things
almost buried in my that's big news at
one time we were gonna have we're gonna
have fatalities 10 times the flu now
we're gonna have fatalities closer to
about the same through the four yeah
about the flow really big news the
mortality rate is it's still not what we
don't want any to be happy with but yeah
it may get a few depression oh yeah it's
great to see